And you are watching I'd like to know
our Bible question and answer program
here at SumTV Answer Secrets Unsealed.
Thank you for joining us and sharing
your day with us. My name is CA Murray.
I'm in the company of Pastor David
Salazar and Pastor Steven Boore. And uh
of course you are here and that makes it
just perfect for us. We've we are
answering Bible questions and um giving
answers from the word of God. Should you
like to have your question answered,
asked and answered here at SumTV, we ask
you to do the following. Send your
question to TV at sums as in marytv.org.
You see it right there on the Chiron TV
at sumtv.org
and we will get to your questions as
quickly and as thoroughly as we possibly
can do. We ask you to do us this one
small favor when you're writing. Let us
know your name at least your first name
and where you are writing from. It gives
us an idea of uh our footprint and what
we're doing to serve the Lord. So if you
do that we would thank you for that in
advance. Pastor Boore, if you would
please ask God's blessing upon this
particular program.
>> Father in heaven, as we begin this uh
Q&A program, we ask for the presence of
your spirit. I ask Lord that you will
give us clarity of thought. Give us
words to speak. Bless those who are
watching that the program might be a
blessing for their own spiritual walk
with the Lord as well.
>> Amen.
>> This we pray in the precious and holy
name of Jesus. Amen.
>> Amen. And amen. Our first question comes
to us from Adam who is writing to us
from South Sudan. And I thank you Adam
for writing us. I know a little bit
about your country. Have some friends
from that country. Sudan has been at war
for many many years. And uh South Sudan
is a really a baby country. I think 2010
or 2011. Um and it's had all kinds of
issues. Uh Sudan in the north is mostly
Muslim. Sud South Sudan is Muslim and
Christian. So, thank you uh for writing
to us. Obviously, you are a Christian
and you're writing to us. So, we want to
take uh some time to deal with your
question, Adam, and to answer it as
thoroughly as we possibly can. I'd like
to know the meaning
uh the I would like to know the meaning
of the book of Daniel 1 through 11 and
the book of Revelation.
um how can I be able to understand them
since they are prophecy? So he he's
dealing Daniel 1-11 and Revelation and I
guess he wants some broad parameters for
understanding these books since they are
prophetic books.
The first thing I would say is each of
the books has some pragmatic things and
has some prophetic things.
The first thing you have to determine
particularly when you're reading Daniel
is what is actually happening and what
is happening uh in the future. [snorts]
The the the the key to understanding
revelation is getting a firm foundation
in the book of Daniel. Um I would say
Daniel before Revelation
>> uh so that you can understand the sweep
of prophetic history uh in its simplest
terms in Daniel and then you can take
some of the things that you've
discovered in Daniel and apply them to
the book of Revelation. There are some
things in Daniel that are very very
they're real, they're per they're
current, they're happening right now.
And those things that are happening
right now, accept them as such. When you
get to Revelation, you're dealing with
more things that have prophetic
significance. And when the Bible tells
you that it's something prophetic like
birds or beasts or countries or kingdoms
that are speaking and doing different
kinds of things, you accept that
prophetically. Now, that's broad brush
strokes. Uh let me guys let you weigh in
and I've got some more things to say
here.
>> Well, the you know, let's start with the
book of Daniel a little bit for for our
friend Adam. The book of Daniel is
really composed of two parts if we can
say that. Uh there is the historical
part chapters 1-6 and then you have the
prophetic which is just prophecies 7
through 12. Uh now in the first part of
the book of Daniel in the historical
part each story it's also a prophetic
concept in in in character. So it
teaches us lessons for the last days.
The book of Daniel has a wonderful
amount of of stories that illustrate
really what's going to happen in the end
time events. And so, uh, you can start
with Daniel and look at the key stories,
understand, get familiar with the story
of Daniel by going through the first six
chapters is really an easy structure to
understand to read what happened with
Daniel, what happened while he was in in
Babylon, what happened with the king
Nebuchadnezzar and all these things. And
you can see these things elements to
understand the stories that are going to
come alive in prophecy as a as an
illustration as a as a way to understand
key concepts in the future. So I would
suggest for him to start reading Daniel
like I said start 1-6 and then uh once
you understand the stories you know what
that stories are about you are going to
be able to understand a little bit
better how those stories reflect the
prophecies that are going to be
presented in the next chapters and again
in revelation. And and when you go into
Revelation, um by having the the the
concepts of Daniel in your mind,
Revelation is really the key that
unlocks
most of the the ideas of of Daniel by
expanding and kind of approaching in a
layer approach. And I think the ministry
here, Pastor Bo, has done a great
amazing job to present these elements of
study. We have study guides on
Revelation. We have a study guides on
Daniel that you can find in our ministry
web page and you can go and study and
realize that these books have been given
to us and have been unlocked have been
revealed have been unsealed so that we
can understand the prophecies and
realize that these prophecies h have
indeed been most of them fulfilled and
what's left is pointing us to the last
part of this great controversy between
good and evil. One of the things and I'm
coming to you pastor because I know
you've got a lot on this to remember in
in particularly in Daniel even in the
historical part you run into Daniel 2.
You run into some things that have
prophetic significance. You will find a
pattern of repeat and enlarge. It's not
you don't necessarily stack them on top
of each other. It's the same but it's
more of the same. Can I can I say that
it's he will give you the same scenario,
the same story but give you different
aspects of that same story so that your
your vision becomes broader as you go
over the same the same material.
>> Bottom line is you cannot study
trigonometry unless you have studied
math before.
>> Exactly. So beginning
>> um don't start uh studying revelation at
chapter 17.
>> Yes. [laughter]
because you won't be able to to uh
decipher it.
>> Um
Daniel has four uh four um chain
prophecies.
>> Mhm.
>> Daniel 2 is the foundational one.
>> Correct.
>> It has all the main details
but that doesn't give you the complete
picture. And this is what you were
mentioning the uh repeating sequence
idea that that we had in our uh anchor
school of theology. uh Daniel chapter 7
supplements what you have in Daniel
>> 2
>> and then uh Daniel 11 which we didn't
cover very much in anchor supplements
Daniel 2 and Daniel 7
>> also Daniel 8 and 9 right supplement
>> and then that does that's not enough
then you have to go to Revelation
>> which supplements and adds to Daniel 2
and Daniel 7 and Daniel 8 through12. And
then that's not enough. You have to go
to Revelation 13
>> and see how it's related to the previous
ones. And then finally, you're ready to
go to Revelation chapter 17.
>> Uh which is the culmination or the
collection of everything that came
before.
>> Uh you can't start in Revelation 17,
work backwards because it won't make
sense. But if you start with the basic
uh vision, uh that would be very
important. Now something that pastor
Salasar said is also extremely important
and that is that the stories of Daniel
are actually prophecies.
>> Yes.
>> You know some people divide Daniel into
uh this the historical section and the
prophetic section. Well, but the
historical section has Daniel 2 which is
a prophecy.
>> Prophecy. Correct.
>> So and it's good, you know, I believe
that Daniel is divided into two parts.
Daniel 1-7
>> and Daniel 8-12. There's two books
within one book, right?
>> Uh I agree 100% with that.
>> Uh but once again, we need to do it in
order because if we don't, we're going
to be totally confused.
>> Absolutely.
>> Um here at Secrets Unsealed, uh we do
have uh Prophecy Repeating Sequence uh
the anchored school notes.
>> Uh also, I'm not sure if they've aired
the uh programs. I think that they have
uh on 3ABN they've aired the uh 24 hours
of instruction. Um and also we have uh
two volumes of study notes on the entire
book of Daniel
>> uh which uh there's almost a thousand
pages in those study notes which would
be a great help and they're available
online if you download our app.
>> Absolutely. You can download the app you
can see go through the whole series you
can get all the materials they're
available for free. So I recommend Adam
and I'm so thankful that he's writing.
God is doing uh and and and putting in
the people's mind the desire to
understand prophecy and I think the Lord
is working in in f in friends and people
around the world who want to understand
this these two particular books who are
key to understand the plan of salvation
and how the lord is going to end the
conflict in this world. uh the
prophecies of Daniel revelation are so
important, so relevant and they will
expand to us the work of Christ and
what's happening in this world and why
we believe that Christ coming soon. Why
we can see that happening and so it
really complements uh each other. They
are built for one another. God made that
clearly in in revelation actually
speaking of of Daniel uh Revelation
chapter 10 speaking of the little book.
So God is certainly working in the heart
of Adam and I pray that he continues to
study uh these two prophecies. But start
like you said, start at the basics,
start at the beginning too.
>> Yeah. And the Lord encourages us to
study them both together,
>> right? [clears throat] Uh
>> uh and you know with AI these days
um people can take those study notes and
translate them into their local
language.
>> It's an amazing thing.
>> Amen.
>> Um AI is a double-edged sword.
>> Yes. It has great dangers.
>> Great dangers.
>> Yes.
>> But it also has great benefits.
>> Amen. Amen.
>> For example,
>> Amen.
>> Um my study notes, you can take a
400page study notes and translate from
translate it from English into Spanish
uh in a matter of a few hours.
>> Yeah.
>> Good Spanish.
>> Mhm.
>> At that, you know, recently that's what
Eileen did with uh with the summit
notes. I had them only in English. She
ran them through AI and I just to make
some minor corrections. So I'm I'm not
recommending that AI is good for
everything but God, you know, television
3ABN is good. It's a lot of things on
television that are not good. So So what
God has made it possible for us to have
the devil is used for evil. Amen.
>> But God uses it for good. Amen.
>> Amen. And even in that historical
section as we we have both said uh there
are prophetic elements there. So it's
Dana is a good place to get your feet
wet to dip your toes in the water as it
were and then as you get stronger in the
Lord uh you can you can wait into
Revelation and get the full picture. So
thank you so very much Adam. We are
praying for you. We're praying for your
country. We are praying for the
Christians and Adventists in your
country uh that you stay strong in the
Lord amid great great trial and uh
tribulation. Thank you Dan. Uh, Adam.
Uh, next is is it Max
>> again? We don't have a place where he's
writing from, but uh, thank you, Max,
uh, for your question. Um, I've been
doing all the reading of questions here.
Pastor Boy, you want to read this
question? Of course. It's a little
lengthy. Um, and it's probably going to
take the rest of the time that we have
for this particular program.
>> I'll do it very quickly. Mhm.
>> would like to know and understand what
did Jesus mean when he said in John
20:17
and then he quotes the verse. Jesus
saith unto her to Mary that is touch me
not for I am not yet ascended to my
father but I go to my brethren and say
unto them I ascend unto my father and
your father and to God and your God.
That's John 20:17.
In my understanding, Jesus immediately
ascended to heaven to present himself
before the father to ensure that his
sacrificial offering was accepted. And
this in turn actuated the sanctuary
service that Jesus would begin to do
once he entered into the heavenly
sanctuary. After his encounter with Mary
in John 20:17,
the next time Jesus appears is in the
room where his disciples were hiding.
Can we assume that following the first
ascension, Jesus then returned back to
earth and dwelt 40 days with his
disciples before going back up to heaven
as we see it in Acts chapter 1. The
parallel connection that I am drawing
here is where Moses inaugurated the
first covenant with the people and God
by sprinkling blood over the tabernacle
and its furniture before the launch of
the sanctuary service. Please see Exodus
20:8 and Hebrews 9:18- 24. I believe
that in the same way Jesus was following
the pattern. Please help me understand
this if I have missed the mark.
So basically a very simple question. Did
Jesus go to heaven at right after he met
Mary in the garden then come back and
meet with his disciples the same
evening? a very
>> and then 40 days later he ascends to
heaven and now he uh he actually
presents himself before his father and
begins his sanctuary ministry.
>> Yes.
>> A very simple answer. [laughter] Yes.
>> Good.
>> He he most of the the only Bible that
says do not touch me I think is the King
James. Uh most of the translations say
something akin to do not cling to me or
do not detain me or do not restrict me.
Um he did make uh and we've talked about
this on on this this program before on
other episodes of this program. He did
make a shall we say quick trip to heaven
y uh to make sure that his sacrifice was
accepted uh by his father and then he
came down. After he came down there was
no more discussion of don't touch me,
don't hinder me uh because that was
taken care of. So the first part of his
his question uh is yes his understanding
of that is is is correct
>> you know and all Bible versions this is
something that many people don't realize
uh most modern versions translate don't
cling to me
>> yes
>> but the interesting thing is this I
think it appears 20ome times this word
in the Greek language
>> and in the modern versions all of them
translate don't king cling to me but in
all the referenc says all the other
references they they try and say don't
touch me.
>> Uh so so really it should be no don't
>> Don't touch me.
>> Uh and what why did Jesus go to heaven?
He presented himself before his father
when he ascended uh the the day that he
resurrected.
>> So what did he go there for?
>> He went there to receive authority from
the father.
>> Yes.
>> The father was going to say your
sacrifice is accepted. I give you all
authority now in heaven and in earth.
And we know that because in Matthew 28
when Jesus 40 days later is about to
leave, he says to his disciples, "All
authority has been given to me in heaven
and earth." He must have gone and
received authority from the he from the
father the day that he resurrected. And
then he comes back and he tells the
disciples, I have all authority now. Uh
go and preach the gospel.
>> Absolutely. Bring it to you.
>> The spirit prophecy in the s of ages
makes it very clear. There's no doubt
that he had to go up to heaven and
return. I will read it to
>> to to the our friends who are here in
watching our program. This is s of ages
page 790
>> and it says uh I'm going to read these
two paragraphs that are very important
and we can get the full picture. uh
speaking of Mary and and the encounter
he had with Jesus, he says, "But now in
his own familiar voice, Jesus said to
her," Mary, now she knew that it was not
a stranger who was addressing her, and
turning, she saw before her the living
Christ. In her joy, she forgot that he
had been crucified. Springing toward him
as if to embrace his feet, she said,
"Raboni." But Christ raised his hand,
saying, "Detain me not, for I am not yet
ascended to my father, but go to my
brethren, and say to unto them, I ascend
unto my father and your father to my God
and your God." And Mary went her way to
the disciples with a joyful message.
Jesus refused to receive the homage of
his people until he had the assurance
that his sacrifice was accepted by the
father. He ascended to the heavenly
courts and from God himself heard the
assurance that his atonement for his the
sins of men and had been ample and
through his blood all might gain eternal
life. The father recti ratified the
covenant made with Christ and he will
receive repentant and obedient men and
will love them even as he loves his son.
Christ was to complete his work and
fulfill his pledge to make a man more
precious than fine gold, even a man that
the golden wedge of a fur. All power in
heaven on earth was given to the prince
of life and he returned to his followers
in a world of sin that he might impart
to them of his power and glory. So here
we have it very clearly as you said he
ascended to the father and he came back
a quick trip to confirm that the
sacrifice and his uh covenant was
accepted by the father
>> and there's a biblical foundation for
this
>> because uh the passover represented the
death of Christ that was the 14th of
>> Nissan. Yes.
>> Um then you have the unleaven bread
>> which represents the burial of Christ
where his body saw no corruption. Mhm.
>> That was on the 15th of Nissan, which
would be Sabbath
>> on Passion Week.
>> Mhm.
>> And then on the 16th of Nissan, you have
the feast of first fruits,
>> where where the priest would go out and
he would uh he would gather uh a sheath
>> Yes.
>> of uh a sheath of uh barley at this
point. And then he would take the sheath
and he would wave it before the Lord.
>> Yes.
uh at the entrance to the sanctuary.
>> Yeah.
>> So Jesus went to the entrance of the
heavenly sanctuary and his father met
him there
>> and he predicted himself as the fruits
first fruits. The apostle Paul calls
Jesus the first fruits.
>> Uh which is the guarantee that there's
going to be the last fruits which are
all of the redeemed. Amen.
>> Because of what Jesus did. So, so the
feast of free first fruits is the
biblical foundation for what Ellen White
has to say in Desire of Ages.
>> Yeah, I I think that that's pretty
clear. Um Ellen White used the term
detain there. uh he needed to get up and
make sure that get up to heaven and make
sure that everything that he had done
was was accepted of the Lord and then
when he came back he could he could do
more uh ministry to his disciples in
preparing them for the time when he
would finally leave he was given the
power he could then pass the power on to
them as they uh spread uh his word.
>> Uh well done good question very well
done
>> and we thank you for that brother. I'm
not sure whether we're going to be able
to answer this next question in the time
constraints that we have.
>> Uh basically it's the uh the
relationship between the word nephesh.
>> Yes.
>> And the word ruach.
>> This is going to take
>> uh it's going to take some time because
we're going to have to read some verses
to show the distinction between Yes.
>> these two uh particular terms in the
Hebrew language.
>> All righty. Let's uh spend the last
little bit. We can we can talk a little
bit more about uh some of the study
notes that we have for some of these
things. You have been over the years
writing furiously
>> uh and um now that uh we have AI we can
translate some of this stuff into the
various languages um particularly as as
they deal with um some of the questions
that we've been talking been talking
about. just give us a quick rundown of
the things that you did at the last
anchor if you can recall and how that
impacts on what we're doing.
>> Okay. Uh I'll do that. But let me just
mention that if you want more on uh the
previous question, the one about uh the
first fruits, I have an entire study
notes
>> on the Hebrew festivals.
>> It's called the Hebrew religious
calendar.
>> Uhhuh.
>> Uh it has probably close to 400 pages or
maybe even more.
>> Wow. where I go through the meaning of
each of the Hebrew festivals and I deal
with some some other issues uh relating
to that like for example the lunar
sabbath and all these other things. Uh
but u also I have study notes on the
sanctuary
>> which uh is is really important series.
uh the last anchor school of theology uh
which was in March of uh of this year
>> um we had a series called prophecies
repeating sequence
and I consider it to be uh in this
period of history probably the most
important study notes that I've ever
written. Uh it shows um the relationship
between Daniel 2, Daniel 7, Revelation
12, Revelation 13, and Revelation 17. Uh
because these chapters need to be
studied in sequence
>> and they need to be studied together
because each chapter builds upon the
previous one. Mhm.
>> Now, we didn't deal with Daniel chap
8-12, which is another chain prophecy
that begins with the Mes and Persians
and then it goes to Greece and and so
on. Uh because uh we wouldn't have been
able to finish the 24-hour class by
studying that passage as well. Neither
did we deal with uh Revelation 11, which
mentions the 1260 days. And then after
that it mentions uh uh you know the
beast that rises from the abyss which is
a French revolution which is also a
chain prophecy that needs to be
connected with these. But if you get
those study notes uh the they'll be
online for free if you download our app.
Uh you can uh get all of the information
that'll help you study these prophecies.
>> Amen.
>> Again we thank you so very much for
joining us and for your questions. Do
get the study notes. They are exhaustive
but not exhausting. And they will
fortify you as you search the Lord. Uh
search your word for the word of the
Lord and walk the road that leads to
glory. Again, we'll see you again soon.
Bye-bye and God bless.